I now have the list of Donald Trump's
foreign bank accounts thanks to the
release of his taxes these are at least
bank accounts we know he held during the
years of the tax returns being released
Newsweek has published an article about
this and it talks about more specifics
but let's start with the list itself and
here it is in 2016 and 2017 Donald Trump
had a bank account in China we'll talk
about that uh in 2016 and 2017 Donald
Trump had a bank account in Ireland a
typical place for reducing reducing
corporate tax liability utilized by many
companies including uh alphabet the
parent company of Google
in 2016 1718 and 2020 Donald Trump had a
bank account in the United Kingdom and
in 2016 Donald Trump had an account in
the Caribbean nation of Saint Martin a
popular but not the most popular place
for offshoring money for the purposes of
tax avoidance now you might say David
sir he's a businessman
he has accounts what's the big deal
there's a lot of a lot of question marks
around some of these things now
generally when a president has bank
accounts in another country there are a
number of questions that we would ask
now this is for a normal person when you
have someone as corrupt and poorly
intentioned to Trump there's other
factors which we will get to but in
general president with foreign bank
accounts conflicts of interest okay U.S
president has bank accounts in other
countries there may be Financial
interests that conflict with the
interest of the United States just
obvious you know all these anti-semitic
right-wingers want to talk about oh
conflict you you might have dual
citizenship with Israel not me but like
some American Jews maybe have dual
citizen Citizenship with Israel but they
don't want to talk about this conflict
of interest money in other countries
this could affect decision making it
could lead to actions that are not
necessarily in the best interest of the
country two we've talked about it before
with Trump vulnerability to foreign
influence U.S president has foreign bank
accounts they could be vulnerable
honorable to influence her coercion from
other countries and it could put the
president in a position where they might
make a decision based on the interests
of foreign entities or of Trump's
interest in those other countries then
what's in the best interests of the
United States three lack of transparency
because remember Trump worked for years
to hide this information U.S president
foreign bank accounts can be difficult
for the public and for Congress to know
what are their financial interests and
that can lead to suspicion and mistrust
and subterfuge legal issues U.S
president having bank accounts in other
countries questions as to are they
compliant with tax law are they
complying with disclosure requirements
Etc and then of course there's
perception however for Trump that's not
a big deal because the people
considering or in the universe of those
who would vote for him don't really seem
to care what he does now a few things to
remember about the China bank account
specifically
uh the Ivanka Trump brand you know they
got a bunch of trademarks approved very
quickly in China while Trump was
president
does that have any connection to the
China bank account we don't know again
it's speculative but these are the sorts
of questions that come up when we find
out Trump is a bank account in China
Trump's Media Group received funding
from a Chinese firm called dwac
uh that's a Chinese firm that lists
Chinese companies on American Stock
markets they are a target of SEC
investigations they have offices in
Wuhan
I'm not conspiratorial but if you want
to start asking questions about Trump
and China rather than fauci in China we
certainly have a lot of fodder for that
that is only bolstered by Trump having a
bank account there uh Trump owes money
to the Chinese government-controlled
Bank of China there's all these
different things so does this
definitively prove any crime or
wrongdoing no I guess not but it
continues to be exactly the type of
information that Trump sought to hide
worked really hard exhausted every
option to try to hide the fact that he
had tried to hide his taxes period and
and of course contained within that is
all this information that we're learning
and we don't really have answers to any
of the questions that we're asking so is
it a surprise that Trump had these
accounts it is not
could it be well you know UK bank
account he has business in the UK sure
could be but every single one of these
really should be investigated and when
you talk one I think back to Jimmy
Carter Jimmy Carter's family had that
Peanut Farm in Georgia
and he I don't remember if it was that
he uh sold his stake or exactly what
Jimmy Carter did but even to avoid the
possible appearance of some kind of bias
Jimmy Carter took steps on that think
about how many decades and Orders of
magnitude we are removed from that type
of accountability and desire to maintain
credibility it's uh it's truly
horrifying we'll continue to learn more
as a result of the tax returns that were
released of course there are only some
elements of them are are redacted as
well so there's even more to learn but
the more we do learn the worse and worse
it looks
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor sure to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below